who do you want to be how do you want to
make your money because it's all about
your positioning in a Marketplace so now
who do you want to be by the way almost
every single time I talk to somebody and
I'll ask them
who do you want to be
these are your positions
you want to be an entrepreneur
do you want to be an investor inventor
CEO founder do you want to be a CEO of a
small business do you want to be CEO of
a big Fortune 500 do you want to be CEO
of a startup do you want to be a sales
guy you want to be volume or high ticket
what's volume I'll do 400 000 loans High
ticket I only do three million dollar
loans
you want to be an influencer I want to
be these guys that you know perfect bot
and I just take a picture and I get 79
000 likes I just want to walk in places
and people take pictures of me I want to
be famous man that's what I want to be I
want to be an influencer podcast
Instagram I want everyone to know me
when I go into the mall or the airport
solopreneur I don't want people to hold
me accountable I just kind of want to be
me I'm like the tennis player I'm the
golf guy it's solo me I'm going to be
able to handle myself no one's as
perfect as me no one's as good as me and
there's nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong with that but that's you and in
their support team I'm gonna support Pat
I don't want to be on the stage I don't
want to be the CEO I'm a good six person
I'm a good eight person I tried being
number one I can't stand it I hate it I
don't want to go to sleep at night
knowing everything's on me I want to go
to sleep at night knowing everything's
on a guy who's got three people then
these people need support and it's me I
like that that's my comfort zone great
or you want to be an entrepreneur you
know what I want to go be part of a
company and within a grow up to be a c i
o c t o c c o c o o whatever and I want
to own a piece of the company but I
don't want to be number one I want to be
an entrepreneur and within the company I
want to think like an entrepreneur and I
want to own a piece of the company and
that's how I want to make my wealth but
that's who I want to be
well most people are like why can't I
like this guy on Instagram maybe I'll be
like him
yeah I kind of like that girl maybe I'd
be like her it'd be kind of cool if I
knew how to take good selfies like her
you know it'd be cool if I can do this
but we don't really know who we want to
be so how do you make your money
wealth marriage married rich person
fastest way to become a millionaire
equity
I want to get a piece of the company I
have someone to create my wealth no
problem
built to sell I want to build a company
running for five years sell it get my 20
million go enjoy myself right that's
what I want to do Buy and Hold domains I
have a collection of a thousand domains
somebody wants to buy this domain 300
000 check eventually I'll make six
million I'm good that's all I want to do
long-term planning the typical get a job
401K all that stuff Lottery be an
influencer if I become an influencer and
every time people want me to do a
certain shout out five thousand dollars
three thousand dollars eight thousand
dollars that's who I want to be
proprietary product to use my product I
keep twenty percent you keep eighty
percent but it's my product invest I
want to invest in a business let
somebody else do the work and I make the
return on the money sue somebody I like
I like to sue people like somebody will
say I want to sue if I sue the right
person make a couple million dollars
there's a lot of people that become
millionaires soon people anybody knows
anybody that's made money soon people
there's a lot of people in America guys
I remember I went to a meeting one time
this guy's giving a talk he says do you
know why kids in America are obese
why are we experiencing so many kids
being heavy
so one guy says video games one guy says
this one guy said he says let me show
you a statistic he shows the statistic
of parks in America
dramatic drop off by 70 shutting down
he says do you know why let me show you
why then he shows lawyers go sit at
parks all day waiting for a kid to drop
off hit their elbow crack the elbow up
is that your son that's not fair with
this it's the city's fault it's the
city's fault come here let me see that
arm perfect I will represent you he's
feeling good are you hurt as a mother I
will get you a million you deserve a
million dollars for this Mary I will
take care of you they go to the city
they sue the city get a million bucks he
keeps 33 330 Grand they get 660 000 next
part shuts down obese obese obese so a
lot of people become resume people this
is a weird world I just don't want to
make it like that right
own land you own land and Walmart says
hey some of you guys have never been to
Palmdale desert seven Walmarts in
Palmdale if you have a land Walmart
comes and says I want this land I'll pay
this much money no problem another way
making millions design inheritance how
many guys have the right last name here
who has the right last name here
anybody's got the right last name yes
how many guys have a last name with your
family so rich that you know that
money's coming to you anybody here any
Kennedy's here
and I Rockefellers
yes any escobars right
Annie El Chapo's in here I don't know we
got some names out there right it's
probably more El Chapo's and escobars
here maybe it could be a difference as
well okay
so how are you going to make your money
so what's your game plan
who are you gonna be how are you going
to make your money by the way just so
you know it is the easiest time ever in
the history of mankind to be a
millionaire
ever
it's the easiest time ever to be a
millionaire it's never been easier than
today ever it's a joke today to be a
millionaire it's a joke today to be a
millionaire it's so uh let me explain it
to you you know how celebrities used to
be like a person was on TV we would be
like oh my gosh Mom look look look look
look it's the weather guy what's the
weather guy Mom it's Burger King it's
1998. it's the weather guy oh my gosh
it's the weather guy mama's crazy
today oh hey John what's up
you know why why because people follow
YouTubers more than they follow weather
weather guys
Instagram influencers have more
following than a weather guy does
it's no longer a big deal to be a
celebrity just so you know social media
here's what it did it made the whole
celebrity thing gone
there is no more value at being a
celebrity yeah PewDiePie is known as
much as some of the biggest Ace the
celebrity Hollywood starts in America in
the world
and he just pays PewDiePie
regular guy Logan Paul Jake Paul it's a
completely different game today being a
celebrity is so easy today making
millions is so easy today your
strategies is what needs help so let's
talk about it
where most people struggle
lens
and language let me speak about lens
first
earlier a guy comes to me
and he starts talking to me and he says
hey you know oh Patrick we were at the
uh how many guys were at the CEO at the
luncheon that they had who was at the
luncheon deal right who was at this
lunch and when this one kid was talking
to me where is he at I want to find him
I'm not going to call him out I just
want to find him is he CEO package guy
or no are you anywhere here wink at me I
got big eyes I'll find you okay all
right all right all right all right all
right let me tell you what this kid did
so he comes up and here's how he starts
it
he says Patrick
I can't even tell you've changed my life
your content is incredible
it's absolutely ridiculous I learned so
much from you and it goes for 30 seconds
no one's doing that so far because they
just want to come and ask a question
because it's another one so I'm thinking
like this is getting somewhere and then
he says
here's my card if you ever want to buy
any real estate in Nevada Vegas just
call me
and I said do you know what you just did
he said what I said what you just did to
me is like a guy at a bar going to a
girl and saying the following thing
saying hey you're so stunning you're so
beautiful oh my gosh you're the hottest
thing here
if you ever want to go to bed call me
I'm like you're serious
I said so let me get this straight your
lens here is you're just looking at
everybody as a customer that's a wrong
Lance
that's a small lens he says what do you
mean I'm just trying to I'm not coming
like that I said you are but the guy had
a good attitude about it I said let me
give you a story
years ago
I had a guy right before me another guy
came up and he said Pat actually I saw
his face uh uh uh he says Pat we know
same name a guy named Eli dafish right
where's the guy that said Eli did you
say Eli so he comes to me and he says
hey Pat we know same name a guy named
Eli and I told him who Eli was to me I
was 21 years old when I met Eli at an
event by LAX airport
so I get close to Eli I get invited to
his 50th birthday party I go to his
house
I'm a nobody I'm selling gym memberships
at Valley Total Fitness a guy comes to
me
he's one of the biggest attorneys in
Vegas it comes to me and and he says so
so I said so what are you doing he says
I'm an attorney for you know for
Hollywood for you know this is why I'm
an attorney he gave me some big names
I'm like okay he says what do you do I
say I work at Bally's it's oh yeah so
you run the casino in Vegas I said no no
no no I'm the I'm the weekend assistant
manager at Valley Total Fitness right oh
oh and you know Eli yeah oh okay very
cool good to meet you right
I stayed the night at the end I'm
washing the dishes for this lady her
name is Julina it's his wife I'm washing
the dishes I talked to Eli I said Eli
how can I help you
he says Patrick you can't really help me
in any way but one way I said what is it
I said my son's in prison for nine years
he said okay
he says he did something he shouldn't
have done I said what prison is he at
Men's Colony anybody knows men's Colony
near San Luis Obispo you don't know it
it's not a good prison it's a hardcore
prison like marascha you know what I'm
saying like it's a hardcore hardcore
prison okay
so he says None of my friends and
relatives want to go visit this guy his
friends don't want to go there I said
I'll go he says you sure absolutely he
says but this is not a regular person do
do background check whatever they got my
back I took 30 days I go to prison I'm
sitting there all day with them in there
he says that guy shank that guy he was
in the hole he just got out he's just
some and he's sitting like this this is
Patrick just said I'm not even kidding
with you guys he's sitting like I never
forget this day we took a picture I got
the picture until today this was picture
was taken 2000. two thousand two
thousand one
so I come back Eli's emotional
he's like I can't believe you just did
that for me I said buddy you know what
do you mean I did that for you it's your
son
he says how can I help you I said I
don't know he says here's the 600 most
influentials name I know you can use my
name to call them to help you out with
whatever you want I said you're serious
yes it's okay I came back I called them
one of the contacts introduced me to
another person who introduced me to
another person who introduced me another
person made me 30 million dollars
one contact
why because I didn't say hey you want to
go to bed
no I went and I said how can I help you
almost everybody in this room
almost everybody in this room all you
have to do is just take the lens off you
have put a different lens on
because when you put a lens on you just
look at the world in a whole different
way you're not looking at everybody here
that I'm just trying to figure out a way
what I can get for me it's a completely
different lens
[Music]